what are some of the other ways that
things have lasted for a very long time
one is to
is to have taken a very long time to
have been built um
and we've mentioned religion before here
as one of the longest lasting
institutions in the world but one of
their structures that they create
are cathedrals and cathedrals have this
interesting properties that many of them
took
decades if not centuries to to build and
you know one of the oldest ones the
cathedral at cologne
germany was started in 1248 it took 600
years to build this cathedral
the most dangerous time you find is for
something to last
is really just a generation or two after
it was first built
or founded and that's because you know
it's the institution
or the the cathedral of your of the last
generation
and it's no longer in fashion often
people find you know a different use for
that
that property um but if you take let's
say
600 years to build it by the time you're
done it's already has
a different type of value to
civilization it's a thing that has value
for its antiquity
and its cultural kind of knowledge um
and relevance and you know we see this
now with even modern
cathedrals that aren't even done so the
the sagrada familiar cathedral in
barcelona
was begun in 1882 we're now almost 140
years into
its construction progress and it's not
done but it's already
a unesco world heritage site and there's
probably few examples of this in the
world but if it lasts long enough even
in its build process
it can become valuable to to a
civilization
and that civilization can then help it
last in fact the tickets
that get sold to come into this thing
are really the way that it's being
funded
to get completed in japan we also find
things like the oldest continuously
standing wooden structures
these temples at nara japan were started
in
607 a.d and they have survived all kinds
of
influxes of government and other
societies and even other religions
to this day really because of slow
careful maintenance the roofs were kept
intact
the main timbers are still the main
timbers but they've replaced little bits
and pieces of the outsides
over time and they've allowed them to
last and they
in turn have helped the institution last
over the same kind of time frame another
example only a couple hours away by
train
but a very different strategy are the um
the ise shrines
in japan and these uh date back almost
two millennia
ago and these temples are built in a in
an interesting way that they're not
built out of very long lasting materials
then they're not necessarily
themselves maintained from year to year
but they're rebuilt
um in exact copies of each other in
alternating sites and so you can see
an image of these temples every 20 years
where
the old one is now being deconstructed
and the new one
is being constructed i was lucky enough
to be there about eight years ago
for the rebuilding of the last temple
when the the now princess of japan moves
the
the kind of cultural treasures from one
to the next and so you have the master
builders who are
in their 80s the last cycle of this 20
years ago when they were in their 50s or
60s
they were the mid-level master builders
and then you have people in their 20s
and 30s who are the new builders
all of them learning how to rebuild this
temple and in turn i think helping that
cultural institution
last itself by reminding that cultural
institution of
the reasons it exists and all of the
rights and rituals that go
along with that